this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist instead of spring cleaning
let's do
some summer simplifying ryan
today on the eve of our 300th
public episode oh wow we're going to
tackle your decluttering
and minimalism questions now first ryan
i have to start with
i was wrong really but then i was wrong
about being wrong
so i don't know if that makes me right
or twice as wrong is that the whole like
uh the idiom of like i was wrong once
but it turns out i was yeah wrong anyway
we for a while we were calling our
audience simpletons and everyone was
sort of in on the joke
and i thought it really didn't catch on
and so i put a poll out there
on our patreon yeah patreon.com
the minimalist shout out to our patreon
supporters and i said
you know maybe we change it maybe we
refer to our audience as minimizers
people were in the process
of minimizing and then
or do you like the do you like
simpletons are you in on the joke and
it was overwhelming right because ryan
and i are the head simple tens
what does simpleton mean it means to be
foolish or gullible
yes aren't we foolish and gullible
and haven't we certainly been for 40
years ryan oh yeah
well hold on i i'm not 40.
that's right you never will be right
that's right
all right i forgot ryan's still a
30-something yes that's right i am for
for the time being
anyway so i put this pull up and
overwhelming
we got like i think a thousand or more
votes over on patreon
oh wow and it was like 70 percent of
people said
no no simpleton like we're in on this
some people like minimize or some people
threw out other
cute monikers like enough ease which i
thought was was funny that's adorable
anyway here's a couple comments here
linda over on patreon said
simpletons makes me smile and i had a
lot of similar comments
like that people say i just get i light
up every time you say
hello simpletons and here's what
carolyn said simpletons if you know you
know
and that was it i mean i thought that
was perfect so here's what i thought we
would do ryan tell me what you think
about this
for these public episodes for our casual
listeners who listen to the public
episodes
we'll call them the minimizers okay and
then
our friends who are in on the joke over
on patreon
they're the simpletons hey man i support
whatever you think man i'm just here
i'm just here to support you brother
well so i was here to say that
i was wrong about i really felt like oh
you know this hasn't caught on
mm-hmm but the patrons absolutely love
they're digging it that's awesome i mean
there were a handful of people were like
i kind of don't get it or whatever
but the vast vat i mean the comments
were amazing the
awesome i was blown away by this cool so
thank you patrons for weighing in on
that
and thank you to the minimizers
listening to this
right now now on this minimal episode
this public episode
we're going to answer your decluttering
questions today we got some about
books we got about a question about
where to start sentimental items
and then on the maximal episode this
week
we're going to talk about why tidying up
doesn't work
we're also going to tell you about the
dinner we had at dave ramsey's house
this week that was pretty awesome yeah
we're going to so we got a story there
now before
we get into the questions ryan i was
walking down santa monica boulevard last
week
and this guy ran into me and he said hey
you're
you're you're one of the minimizers
right
that's awesome and i said yes yeah uh he
goes i saw
both of your films i got to tell you man
i
am a hoarder i'm like a real hoarder i
really enjoyed your films they made me
realize
that i need to make a change can i get
both of those on dvd
[Laughter]
oh the irony that's great oh man and i
said you know i'm sorry man
i think the first film was available on
dvd for a while uh
we stopped it not a lot of people were
getting the dvd i mean it was
hundreds of people and it just it didn't
make sense because you know tens of
millions or probably over 100 million
people have seen the first
film and now and then the the new one
less is now was never on dvd it's a
netflix original
and so it's available there plus even if
i did have the dvds for you man
i know where you're at right now because
i was exactly where
you are i was there
once upon a time and i thought having a
thing
to fix my problem with things was going
to be the
thing that solved everything yeah
and of course it wasn't how did he
respond to that
he i think he was great he he
appreciated that i was being gracious i
gave him a hug and said
hey man you know we had a new book come
out but even that
i wouldn't encourage you to hold on to
it i would go to local library it's
right down the street
and they'll be able to get you a copy if
you want to take a look and have a
deeper dive so we don't need to like
start
walking around carrying dvds on us just
to hand out
just blank tv could you imagine if you
did though like for some reason you're
like yeah here you go
hey do you like mixtapes
you're running hollywood slinging dvds
we have a question from jennifer
on facebook where do you start when your
entire home
needs decluttering it's kind of
paralyzing
here's the thing i'll say ryan is i
wouldn't start with the stuff
and isn't that a weird statement coming
from
one of the minimizers yeah
so as a minimalist yes everything i own
serves a purpose or brings me joy the
excess is out of the way
but it didn't start with the stuff as i
said on the maximal we're going to talk
about why
tidying up doesn't really work and what
i really mean
by that and so if we start with the
stuff
we think we have a stuff problem right
and if we
do have a stuff problem it's not really
about the stuff the thing is not about
the thing right
our material possessions are a physical
manifestation of what's going on inside
us
yeah and so yes we're going to address
the physical clutter
but there's always that question that we
start with it's a why question disguised
as a how to question
because as kapil gupta says we are
smitten with prescriptions
smitten by prescriptions and that
question is how might your life be
better
with less that's always where you start
yeah because i could say oh you start
with your kitchen right
right how many people have started with
their kitchen and they declutter the
kitchen
and a month from now a week from now a
year from now it's re-cluttered
in fact we're going to do a recluttering
episode in the not too distant future
because we're in this new studio and i
found that we are
we are re-cluttering the space in order
to make it ideal for us and so i want to
as
soon as we get through all the lessons
of this new space
i want to be able to talk about those by
the way shout out to andy who's here
helping us with some of the audio
stuff that we're going through right now
that's why we sound so beautiful today
ryan he put a auto-tune on your voice so
it sounds amazing
and everything rhymes for some reason no
minimizers
everything rhymes for some reason so i
get it
where you are it's kind of paralyzing
right well let's talk about why it's
paralyzing there's this
confucius sentiment i'm not going to get
the quote verbatim here
but maybe sean you can find the exact
quote and put it in the show notes as
one of our
minimal maxims not from us but from
confucius
but he says the man that pursues
happiness
is really pursuing change in order to
pursue happiness
one must pursue change unfortunately i
think what we
often do is we pursue a fixed state
and what i mean by that is like oh if i
just had the right stuff in my kitchen
then it would be
complete or it'd be done right or if i
just had
the the right car well then that would
be taken care of
right but that's just tethering us to
a fixed state of things relying on the
externalities once again
to complete us nothing wrong with the
things you and i agree on that
you got here in a car today no mule
right
and um and and as a result we need
some things but when we think those
things are going to be the final state
that once i have everything perfectly
tidy
well now it's all set that's sort of the
ocd mindset i know as a person who has
been
formally diagnosed with ocd i know that
what drives me is this completion state
as soon as i get everything perfectly
organized and straight then
i'll be able to do whatever i want to do
well not realizing that well the whole
point of freedom
happiness peace whatever you want to
call it is we are going to change as our
circumstances change
if we become fixed we become
unhappy you could tweet that podcast
sean boom
man uh no i totally agree i mean you
start with the why
because like we often say you could run
dumpster throw everything out and be
utterly miserable if you don't know why
you did it
uh but the one thing i really want to do
recommend to jennifer the
the most important thing you can do to
get started
is to get started it doesn't matter how
you start
so let's say you've gotten to the why
let's say
uh you know you you can emotionally
understand
where you're at why you have this
clutter and so now you're looking to
actually move on to the things
it's you have to start like right now
just open up a drawer
pick something out put it in a donation
box yeah or maybe you call a friend
you're like hey i got a
spork for you whatever it is the the the
30-day minimalism game i think is like
an awesome way to start yes because it's
uh i'm sure everyone listening to this
knows about it but i'll tell you anyway
it's
you got some new minimizers here that's
right right so here's how you do at
minimizers you
find a friend or a family member or
co-worker someone who wants to declutter
and you agree to play this game the way
the game works
is you start on the first day of any
month so when's this episode coming out
comes out on the third so you're already
two days behind but you can catch up
today yeah you could
actually yeah you could just retro go
back and and start this game so
on the first day of the month you both
agree to get rid of one item and then on
the second day of the month you both
agree to get rid of two items and then
on the third day of the month three
items so forth and so on you'll probably
get the point by now
it starts out really really easy so
right now if it's day three yeah
go back you gotta throw away one two and
then today three things it's six things
total that's a pretty good start but it
gets a little harder as the time
moves on as the month moves on you know
on day 19 you got got to get rid of 19
things
and then 20 things and it gets a little
bit more difficult so whoever
lasts the longest wins and you can bet
something silly i don't know the loser
has to wear a silly hat for a day i
don't know you can streak around the
neighborhood
[Laughter]
what is this what is this high school
yeah yeah you remember that right i do
yeah yeah oh shoot we have to talk about
that on the max yeah right
so yeah although the statue of
limitations has
long passed yeah no so we can't yeah we
can't be true if you really want to get
aggressive with the game
you could just double it every day and
by the end of the month you'll have
gotten rid of a billion items
yeah that's yeah wait
you had me until the billion items i
mean if you got a lot of stuff that
otherwise no by the end of the month you
know the doubling effect it
it'll really really get to you that's
what people often get confused so we
actually have a free calendar you can
download the minimalists.com
game and it will show you how many items
to get rid of that day and it will also
show you how many items you've gotten
rid of so far
that month yeah because if you make it
into the month yeah
yeah whoever makes it the end of the
month wins it if you both make it to the
end of the month
then you both win because you would have
gotten rid of about 500 items or if you
double it about a billion items
no well when you said that it made me
think about that uh
that that gal on the
the minimalist.org uh yeah the the
online city
and she has been playing that i don't
know if she's still playing it it was
many many months
yes and i don't she kept starting over
each month though right that's correct
yeah we've had some people who go beyond
the 30 days or 31 days in a month and
they're like i'm on day 46
yeah of the minimalism game so i'm
getting rid of 46 items today
other people they just start over each
month so it's day one once again
yeah my wife and i do it once or twice a
year still yeah yeah
ella's things they're so easy to get rid
of and we just ripped them out of our
hands
and she's crying you don't need this
you're a minimalist now ella oh shoot
no we would never do it and so it's not
about getting rid of someone else's
things but you can't have your kids
participate ella actually loves
participating in this
and because she realizes the gift of
contribution yeah and she's at that age
now she's eight
where she starts to realize like if i
give this to someone else she
she really started to understand around
right around four or five but now it's
really sinking in
she gets the joy the compersion from all
other kids
are going to enjoy this toy that i am no
longer enjoying
yeah kids get the contribution part
pretty easily and yeah they love
us yeah kid yeah absolutely so jennifer
enjoy that minimalism game
the calendar is at the minimalists.com
game we'll put a link to that in the
show notes
as well we have a question here from
elizabeth in
phoenix arizona i have many hundreds of
books and have been donating them
a little at a time i'm now ready to
instead
keep only the ones i really want and get
rid of the rest
my question has to do with the paperback
books that are decades old and yellowed
with pages falling out they aren't
readable anymore and need to be recycled
but i'm having trouble with the thought
of physically throwing a book away
even in the recycle bin there are they
are my friends
and now i'm constraining them to the
trash never to be read again
how do i get past this i'm gonna give
you some tough love here elizabeth
your books are not your friends and i
get it we tell ourselves these lies all
the time
in fact in our new book a lot of people
use things there's a whole chapter in
there about
our relationship with the truth and it
gets really slippery
not just our relationship with the truth
with others we certainly tell others
lives but quite often we tell others
lies because
we lie to ourselves or here's a nicer
way to say it we create a narrative in
our mind
that my books are my friends and i
totally get it because my stuff
was my friend especially when my
marriage ended and i was surrounded by
things
and i felt like oh i don't have the
person i love
anymore but in a way in a perverse way i
felt like my things loved me
and it's even more insidious with books
because i get it a great book is an
exchange of consciousness you can read a
david foster wallace book right now or
an anthony demelo book right now
they're not alive but you can have an
exchange of consciousness
with another human being who is no
longer here
you can read a marcus aurelius book from
2 000 years ago
and have an exchange of consciousness so
i can understand
the confusion and so it sounds to me
like we need to change the narrative
around
these books because letting go is not
something you do
letting go is something you stop doing
you stop clinging
to the stuff but you also stop clinging
to the past you stop clinging to the
idea that your books are your friends
right there's nothing inherently wrong
with books but what is
useful with books is it the book no of
course not the artifact is
literally meaningless however
there's tremendous value in the words
now not the words alone i could
take our book there's 80 000 words in it
or 100
000 words whatever it is and i could put
all those words into a bucket for you
they're also meaningless right it's the
experience of going through
the book absorbing that but then also
being able to move on from the book it's
the reason that ryan you end
every chapter and love people use things
with some questions
some points of reflection because yes
you might learn something from the
stories in there and it might even
seep into your viscera but
what questions does that lead to because
those questions and also you have some
do's and some don't some boundaries you
help
people set up at the end of every
chapter and what we're really talking
about here with your books
are boundaries i know i did one of the
few solo podcasts i did when ryan was
out of town i think
sean i think it's episode 254 if i'm not
mistaken
either way we'll put a link to it in the
show notes it was about book clutter so
there's a whole episode about
book clutter there and i addressed some
of the misunderstandings that we have
about our books i can tell you one
boundary that i have for me is i have
two bookshelves there these vertical
bookshelves and about
40 books fits on each one so i have 80
books
roughly every time i bring a new book
home and how many people give us books
we were just in nashville and
i think we got three or four books there
yeah now if i want to bring them into my
home
that means i have to take four books off
of my shelf already
and i have to bring them somewhere else
and
it's funny i saw this meme ryan maybe
jordan you could find this put it on the
the youtube video
this meme you know the meme of the guy
holding hands with his girlfriend he's
turning around but he's looking at the
posterior of another girl
oh yes yeah and there's always like some
sort of words over each
right and he's holding hands with the
books i own and but he's looking at
the books i want to buy yeah and isn't
that always the case when you go to the
bookstore
yeah oh i want this one and this one i
can walk to the counter with a stack
of books in fact that podcast episode i
mentioned jordan took the
picture for the thumbnail it's just me
with this huge stack of of
my quote favorite books but why are they
my favorite books
because i've gotten immense value from
them now why do i hold on to some books
why do i hold on to roughly 80 books
because i continue to get value from
some books that i
return to however if i'm not returning
to it
then i start implementing some of our 16
rules for living with less
and maybe it's the seasonality rule have
i read this book in the last 90 days
if not you know i've never read this
book well let's be honest with yourself
josh are you going to read
the next 90
[Music]
maybe okay let me give myself a deadline
then let me
write here's my deadline in the front
cover of the book
that's a good idea and now all of a
sudden i have a deadline if i don't
start the book by then
i give myself permission to let it go
yeah so no i think boundaries would
certainly help elizabeth here
i i do want to i want to acknowledge
like the the battle
that you're going through right now
elizabeth the books are my friends i
mean like i felt that
viscerally when she said that yeah me
too and
there is some there's just something
deeper going on
that maybe elizabeth hasn't been able to
uncover
and her books being her friends is what
helps her deal with that internal
whatever she has going on internally um
or cover it up
yeah or covering it up yeah but you know
i think about like i think about
elizabeth's question i think about
jennifer's question
and what i love about what we did with
love people use things
is i feel like we did an amazing job
to show people where to focus with their
time
their attention we picked these seven
essential relationships that we think
are the most important relationships in
our lives
yes people are one of those but we go
into you know money our stuff
the truth so that internal i'm not
saying that our book is the answer for
elizabeth here but
i do think that if she can read a book
like this
she can start to uncover
why she's having this internal struggle
is it because she might be having a
struggle
with herself she might be having a
struggle with
the truth um and we cover self and truth
in that book
right um man i feel like i feel like
this is a shameless plug for her well no
here let's do this elizabeth we'll send
you a copy of the book yeah if you want
the audio if you like our podcast you'll
really enjoy the audiobook
version so we'll send that to you or if
you want the e-book that might be better
for elizabeth here the e-book's not a
physical line right yeah right right
it's funny we're sending her a book for
her book problem yeah and so that that's
what i want to avoid right and so maybe
the audiobook or the e-book in your case
in particular will be really useful the
other thing i'd love to send you
elizabeth before we wrap
up your question is you're in phoenix
we're going to 20 different
cities throughout the united states and
canada why don't you come experience
let's put you on yeah and so we're going
to send you a couple tickets
to our phoenix event we have 20 cities
for the love people
use things tour and we'd love to see you
we'd love to answer any questions you
might have in person maybe we can have a
conversation
on the live version of the podcast as
well so we'll be in phoenix 19 other
cities
above minimalists.com tour if anyone
else listened to this is interested oh
man i can't wait to get back on the road
but but getting back to elizabeth um
yeah like there's something deeper going
on elizabeth and i i don't know what
that is from your question here in your
voicemail but
uh i i would encourage you to start
digging a little bit deeper to see why
your your books being your friends it
brings her so much comfort there's a
reason for that
the other thing that comes to mind and
it's funny because like i never would
have suggested this
until we did the podcast with ian but
elizabeth you might want to take the
enneagram test to see where you're at on
the enneagram because i know for me
like when i i we were on a podcast i
think we're going to talk about it in
the maximal episode right yeah
but real but real briefly was on this
podcast with with uh a
typology or yeah typology and
kron is the the founder of it and what
he does is he basically
takes your enneagram number and then you
have a conversation about your enneagram
number
and to me i look at the enneagram like
it was at myers-briggs
very surface yes it kind of hints to
what i am
but you know i don't want to like put
myself in this box but what the
enneagram does
is it says hey there are nine different
types you're all of them but let's talk
about which ones surface for you the
most where's your biggest flaws in a way
right exactly so now that i understand
that i'm a seven on the enneagram like i
can just look at things with a different
perspective so when i have these
impulses when i have these
feelings uh it helps me to just manage
them a little bit differently it helps
me to hold space for them
a little bit differently and for the
sake of time i'm gonna like wrap it up
with elizabeth here but
go take the enneagram test and uh get
ian's book
and oh yeah i don't want to recommend
another book to her you could google it
you don't even have to get ian's book
take the enneagram test and then just
look up the strengths of your enneagram
number
look at the flaws and i promise you you
will learn something about yourself
elizabeth enjoy our copy hopefully our
audio copy or ebook copy
of love people use things because the
opposite never works and
we will see you when we come to phoenix
later this year
i just thought if elizabeth if she gets
our book if she gets ian's book
if she does the one out or one in 20 out
rule uh-huh or one in 10 out
for each that's 20 out right yeah that's
true that's one of the rules in our book
one in 10 out yeah you bring one thing
in you have to let go
of 20. so the problem isn't that some of
these books you don't want to recycle
even though they're not
usable you can recycle them you've
determined that they are
functionally trashed they're
functionally useless no one else is
going to get value from it
yes the better thing to do with them is
to recycle them because otherwise
they're just taking up space in your
home
more importantly elizabeth they're
taking up space in your mind
we'll see you soon in phoenix ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it's
time for our lightning round where we
answer your text messages you can text
your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning round so ryan and i do our
best to answer questions for the short
shareable less than 140 character
response
we put the text to these minimal maxims
in the show notes so you can copy and
share our pithy answers
on social media if you'd like and now
you can find all of our minimal maxims
in one place
minimalmaxims.com ryan before we get to
mike's question here also you can text
that phone number
it really does go to both of our phones
we answer a lot of people's questions
all outside of the podcast as well not
every single day but most days
we're responding to people and i'll tell
you this
you can just text us an emoji of the
thing you got rid of most recently and
hopefully elizabeth you'll text us
a emoji of a book because i'd love to
see
that and by the way when you do that
we'll also put you on our monday morning
minimal maxims text message you start
your week off
with a little bit of simplicity mike has
a question for us you know sometimes i
get those
those uh maxims and that's like
something i said and i'm like
man i'm freaking i can't believe i said
that like i don't even remember saying
that
actually what it is is probably sean
clear cleaning it up in post and making
it
beautiful all right let's get to my
question sorry uh what about items
that have a sentimental attachment yeah
what about them
so here's the thing let's talk about
clinging for a second i'll give you a
pity answer real quick
if everything is sentimental then
everything
loses its sentiment and i
recognized this early on in the process
of
letting go when i was going through my
mom's stuff
and everything was sentimental to me
especially because i was so close to her
death
she had just died hours ago
and i'm in this room of hers and all of
these things
not only that have i imbued them with
meaning before
but now i'm dealing with them with all
of this additional
meaning about who she is what it
means to me and
what does clinging do to us clinging
tethers us to a past which by the way
doesn't exist the past
exists only as memories
in the present moment right well of
course the memories aren't in our things
we
elucidated that in our most recent film
which is called less is now on netflix
and
in that film you saw me going through my
mom's things and learning some of those
lessons about dealing with her stuff
and yes while we are giving things
sentiment
be simply because i'm saying that is
sentimental
to me and it's almost as though we're
looking for the right
things i i thought about this um the
story
have you heard of uh nest rudin no he
was a moolah i think
13th century what's a mullah like a
a sufi mystic islamic mystic okay
and a lot of countries claim him that he
was born and
and what some people think is
present-day turkey or
azerbaijan or or maybe i think the
greeks claimed him at one point or the
persians claimed him
he must be a pretty awesome man yeah
yeah and he
he told these sort of stories and he was
often the sort of main foible
in the story he was uh in some ways the
gesture
the gesture of the story he was showing
the
absurdity of some of our chases and
pursuits
through the storytelling and it was
in many ways how you and i we call
ourselves the the simpletons right
and it's because hey we're showing how
foolish we are and he kind of did
the same thing but 700 years ago or 800
years ago now i guess
and anyway there's this one story of him
he's in the town square and he's playing
uh he has his guitar and he's playing
one note
over and over and over and the crowd
starts to
to gather around him and someone in the
crowd eventually says uh
excuse me but why are you everyone else
they play these beautiful
melodies and they they find all of these
different notes
and how come you're just playing the one
note over and over and he said all those
fools they're
constantly searching for the right note
and i've already found it that's awesome
and that's really what we're doing with
our sentimental items
we're clinging to the right notes
think about when you listen to some of
your favorite music ryan
in fact i heard this week when you and i
were in nashville you were talking to
someone he said i've got this song
stuck in my head yeah that becomes a
curse after a while right yes
when you experience the song though it's
beautiful it's perfect
but as soon as you cling to the song
now it's stuck and you become
stuck in a way and it creates a sort of
misery or a discontent
or just a dis-ease and unease with the
situation
because what are we doing we're no
longer hearing the symphony we're no
longer hearing the song
we're clinging to the one note we heard
a day ago an hour ago a minute ago a
year ago whatever it
is and we're having trouble letting go
yeah hey mike there's nothing wrong with
sentimental items
i mean i've got a couple sentimental
items um but i mean
josh you are absolutely right when
everything is sentimental then nothing
is sentimental
it has it loses all meaning when
everything has meaning
so here's how you know whether or not
sentimental items are a problem
it's not worth it when the cost of your
sentiment is your sanity
so what i mean by that is
if you are struggling mentally if it's
weighing on you
elizabeth the books are weighing on her
you can tell there
it's a sign that that's when you need to
let go
so uh don't let don't let don't let it
cost your sanity mike
yeah indeed well ryan we've got so much
more to talk about but first
what do you got for us here are some
voicemail comments and insights from our
listeners
check them out hi i'm kerry from denver
with a tip about answering the
what do you do question i love your
advice about answering that question by
saying what i'm passionate about
but i found that my answers were being
dismissed a little bit
maybe because i'm a stay-at-home mom and
there's a little bit of like an entitled
stigma attached to that role
so i tweaked my response now i answer
with
i work really hard at maximizing the
things that matter most to our family
i'm an ambassador of purposeful living
so to speak and then i go on to talk
about writing
and camping and the other things that
i'm passionate about and ask the other
person what they are passionate about
it's opened up some really incredible
conversations and i'm so grateful for
your advice
hi my name is tracy willis and i live in
sioux falls
south dakota i have a comment i was
listening to your vermont show and
somebody asked about children
and how to be a minimalist with all this
stuff that comes with that
and i wanted to share a couple of tips i
have a one-year-old
and we started our minimalism journey
when i was seven months pregnant before
she was born a couple tips i have
learned
over the last year or so is um our fault
for gifts ask for passes or memberships
to local museums
zoos gymnastics centers etc these get
you and your child out of the house and
engage you in your community there's
also
extra perks discounts or special events
for members that
that come with those passes and it's a
really great way to do it another thing
is oftentimes children under two are
free for those so really your membership
only includes you
um maybe your other family members are
plus ones
as far as toys go rental services exists
in many places
our local library for example allows uh
has a toy lending service
so you can rotate toys out and take them
back without cluttering up your space
there are also online subscription
services that uh
that are similar one local one for us is
called bloombox
and it has really beautiful toys and
educational activities that go along
with them
that you rent uh for a month and send
back
um another thing about toys is that i
found is
designating a space in your home to keep
those toys
so that they're not ending up everywhere
around the house um
really helps you to kind of keep a
manage what you actually have
and once that space fills up you can get
rid of those
toys or let go of toys toys can also be
donated if they're in good condition to
daycare centers
children's hospitals shelters etc
you can also sell them at stores like
once upon a child
as far as clothes i've found going for
second hand
is very helpful as many of the clothes
get ruined or messy anyway
often also the child grows out of
clothes before they're able to wear them
very much
so it's nice to not have spent a ton on
it
and no matter what baby clothes are
pretty much cute because they're tiny
and cute
thredup is another great website that i
use to buy things
that are in great condition as well as
once upon a child
and then finally with accessories try a
packing party with your bottles your
towels your bibs
anything um that isn't like the toys and
everything
uh and if you don't use those things in
21 days you probably don't need them
all right y'all we have a bunch more
surprise questions this thursday on
patreon that's the maximal episode on
the minimalists
private podcast that's for our simpleton
friends
over there that's uh patreon.com the
minimalist but first
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists
so ryan i put out this twitter poll i
printed it out here and i said
raise your hand if you're coming to one
of our upcoming tour stops which city
how far are you traveling we're
simplifying 20 cities across the united
states and canada
which part of the event are you most
excited about and i was so
thrilled by this because i was so
surprised by the answer so
these upcoming 20 events have four
different unique parts
there's a minimalism talk there's a book
reading there's a live podcast and
there's an audience q a now they all
will blend together in different ways
but
fundamentally all four of these
components will be at every event now we
might also have some surprise musical
guests some surprise
podcast guests so there's other
adornments that you will experience
from our live events and i was just
blown away ryan so
53 of the people said the thing they
were most looking forward to
is the minimalism talk that starts out
the show awesome
and i was i mean for me uh i i just
didn't i didn't have any expectation
here
but that was so it was so
disproportionate like i want to see you
guys give a talk about
minimalism a lot of people say i've
never seen you talk about it so we're
bringing a brand new talk
that has never been seen before on tour
also the live podcast the book reading
the audience q
a here's the good news though you don't
have to pick just one
you've got all four we're coming to a
bunch of cities we're going to be
in florida orlando we'll be in nashville
we'll be in atlanta we're going to start
the tour in texas
three cities in texas san antonio
houston dallas
we're gonna be in the mountain states
phoenix and denver and salt lake city
now some of these are smaller venues and
in fact i just sent a screenshot to jess
our social media
social media manager this morning and i
said hey look at new york like
all the seats are almost taken already
and they've only been on sale for less
than a week at this point
and so now incredible yeah it really is
i mean it's great to see that people
were finally getting back out and were
able to do some live events after a long
time
it's my favorite part of what we do man
this game here is getting on the road it
really is
and everything about it is actually one
of my least favorite parts the the
traveling
and every the public speaking yeah
that part is just a irrational fear of
mine but
really what i enjoy is that
i guess you could call it communion the
time together with people
we have some of that here with the
podcast you're listening to this at some
point in the future
after i've recorded it after ryan has
recorded it
but in live events we're experiencing
this
all together yeah and it's one night
one night only in in your town we'll be
in a bunch of cities
uh new york boston d.c minnesota we'll
be in minneapolis we'll be in columbus
toronto i'm trying to do it off top of
my head here
chicago la san francisco seattle
vancouver 20 cities total
yeah theminimalists.com
tour to find the city closest to you
what i love about it man is
it's just a night where people from all
walks of life get together
you're like you leave the dogmatics
outside you leave the politics outside
and you unite around this one very
simple
not easy but this one very simple
concept that word unite
really stands out yeah absolutely man
yeah so join us for a night of unity
yes we simplify your city for one night
only
i had this great testimonial from kelly
over on patreon she said great book i
was so pleased with the depth and truth
of your new book love people use things
it took
everything to a deeper level i was so
inspired i bought
tickets to your live event and then i
decluttered some more
and so i think what's nice here is we're
sort of blending the two i mean you
don't have to read the book in order to
attend one of these live events in fact
i'm going to read
from the book to you in a way and so
we're going to do a little bit of
reading we're going to
answer your questions but we're just
going to have a night together i'm
grateful for that
if you want to come out it's the
minimalists.com tour get your tickets
while you can for our added value this
week ryan
i um this might be my favorite song of
the year so far
and i was playing it in here for you the
other day i think or maybe we were
playing on the road
the kid leroy has a song with justin
bieber it's called stay
now bex and i we have this uh segment on
her podcast her podcast is called how to
love by the way
spotify apple wherever you listen to
podcasts but we do this
segment called terrible love it's really
about the terrible love advice you get
from songs
because when you think about it so many
great songs have
just when you really look at the lyrics
it's like oh my gosh
i i feel this but it is such bad
advice or perspective or ideology right
and so we did a whole breakdown of this
song thankfully justin bieber comes in
and actually saves the song
talking about love and it seems like he
has developed a more thorough
understanding of love
but the kid leroy is a teenager and so
he's still really struggling with the
the concept and the needing the clinging
the attachment
in such a beautiful song this is stay
from the kid leroy
and justin bieber by the way we have a
bunch more surprise questions this week
like
what is the difference between hoarding
collecting and
archiving how do you maintain minimalism
in your kitchen
specifically the kitchen cupboards
fridge
and freezer what if your spouse is not
on board with
minimalism and it causes conflict how do
i determine the line between holding on
to
things to sell versus donating them
plus a million more questions for the
minimalists and if you want to hear all
that
join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app
you'll get access to all of our archives
all of our ask the minimalist anything
sessions we have 47 of those over there
right now
also our entire community we talked
about community already ryan but there's
an entire community
of five or six thousand people over
there right now that you can interact
with
comment on share your decluttering
experiences your relationship
experiences it's pretty amazing over
there
it really is i mean some amazing
open-minded people
it's beautiful also our event archives
ryan and i have done nine tours in the
last 10 years
many of them are recorded audio and or
video and you can check those out
exclusively
on patreon plus any of our new upcoming
tour stops
our true fans and vips get access to all
of the recordings of
all of our live events over on patreon
you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram
at the minimalist if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast email a voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
any new minimalist writings that we
publish
for free right there in your inbox and
if you leave here today
with just one message let it be this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it